o olá pessoal eu sou mario kamia e
gostaria de contar uma história para
vocês por isso eu trouxe aqui essa corda
eu digo que talvez as pessoas deveriam
ser como uma corda firmes e ao mesmo
tempo flexíveis para nos adaptar
rapidamente com essas mudanças do mundo
porque geralmente as pessoas seguem o
ciclo assim como esse laço mas num
determinado momento da vida surge uma
crise que corta este nosso ciclo
bom e nos sentimos pequenos diante desse
desafio mas eu digo que com criatividade
nós conseguimos sim superar os desafios
e o melhor disso é que aprendemos com
tudo isso e podemos crescer mas as
pessoas continuam novamente o ciclo
é dessa maneira tinha um outro momento
surge uma pandemia que corta novamente o
nosso ciclo e essa pandemia fica como nó
no nosso caminho mas com fé e
pensamentos positivos nós eliminamos
isto e seguimos o nosso caminho do
desenvolvimento bom gostaram da mágica
todo mundo pede para ensinar o número de
mágica então vou ensinar o número de
mágica para vocês eu quero que vocês
prestem bastante atenção e vou explicar
também como é que o mágico consegue
iludir as pessoas então vou já tô
explicando para você que eu vou iludir
você e vou ensinar o número de mágica e
depois você também pode fazer essa
mágica para quem você quiser você pode
aplicar esse teste para qualquer pessoa
tudo que vocês vão precisar então um
objeto muito simples que vocês vão
encontrar aí na sua casa que é
a cartolina como essa não sei que vocês
vão desenhar colar o pintar um ponto
vermelho igual a isso é importante dessa
mágica é só lembrar da ordem porque de
um lado vocês vão colar apenas um ponto
do outro lado são dois pontos do outro
lado são três e do outro são quatro
pontos é bem simples né não entenderam
eu vou explicar de novo para vocês de um
lado é um ponto só do outro lado é que
são dois do outro lado são três e do
outro são quatro pontos tá vendo tudo
isso não passa de uma ilusão de ótica na
verdade quando eu digo que tem um ponto
aqui eu estou mentindo na verdade
existem dois pontos olha só o outro está
escondido atrás da minha mão tá vendo
então cubra aqui digo que tem um ponto e
incrível todo mundo acredita e para todo
mundo pensar que são três é só cobrir
desse lado e mostrar bem rápido né tá
vendo e olha só como é que funciona esta
mágica através do nossos paradigmas é
porque
14 um quadrado desse jeito um ponto aqui
no meio vocês vão buscar na memória um
modelo de isso daqui que seria um dado
então no dado você sabe que existe um
ponto aqui quando é um ponto e quando
são três pontos eles estão posicionados
aqui você não está enxergando o terceiro
ponto mas na sua mente você tá buscando
aquele modelo então você acredita que
aqui eu tenho o outro ponto então assim
que os mágicos eles criam as ilusões
quebrando os paradigmas se você não
tivesse esse modelo de dado essa mágica
não daria certo para você então olha só
vou mostrar então como é que você vai
fazer esse número bem devagarzinho para
vocês entenderem bem cobre aqui um ponto
olha só cobrir aqui dois pontos cubra
aqui três pontos e cobre aqui quatro
pontos tá vendo mas eu vou dar uma dica
muito importante quando vocês fizeram
essa mágica porque às vezes
a falar tira a mão aí mostra para mim o
terceiro ponto aí sim você vai usar a
criatividade e mostrar que tem três
pontos aqui do outro lado a mesma coisa
você faz um passe mágico mostra que tem
quatro pontos desse lado mas eu gosto de
complicar um pouquinho mais então mostre
desse lado tem cinco pontos e do outro
lado tem seis pontos você vai ver que no
final todo mundo vai bater palmas
e esse quadro representa como nós
queremos a nossa vida tudo se encaixa
perfeitamente dentro do quadro
a cada peça representa saúde dinheiro
família felicidade carreira
espiritualidade nós temos isso sob
controle por mais que algumas vezes
ficamos confusos
e nós sabemos a direção
e aí
e no entanto a nossa vida é dinâmica e
muitas vezes ela traz desafios que pode
ser um casamento a chegada de um filho
ou uma mudança no trabalho que nos pega
de surpresa à primeira vista pensamos
que não é possível fazer parte da nossa
vida mas então
se encaixamos essa peça
e aí
o que aprendemos com essa experiência
bom e quando a gente acha que já está
tudo ajustado bem um outro desafio
o que pode ser uma separação morte de
alguém querido ou uma demissão é difícil
perceber que isso também faz parte do
nosso quebra-cabeça
é mas quando integramos esta experiência
nos transformamos
e nós transformamos em sabedoria e a
gente aprende que todos esses desafios
que nos desestruturam na verdade nos
transformam e nos amadurecem
internamente mas por fora
e continuamos os mesmos
[Música]
e aí